texte vigilance sanitaire c'est la boîte
à outils de l'exécutif pour lutter
contre l'épidémie de kovy de 19 parmi
les outils validée par les députés
l'article 2 adopté in extremis par les
députés 74 voix pour et 73 contre il
permet donc à l'exécutif de prolonger
l'obligation du pass sanitaires pour les
huit prochains mois et en enjambant la
présidentielle même chose pour le régime
de sortie de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
prolongé donc jusqu'au 31 juillet 2022
ils permettent au gouvernement de
déclencher à tout moment en fonction de
la situation sanitaire des mesures
restrictives couvre-feu confinement ou
simplement des limitations de
circulation des mesures qui pourraient
coincer chez les sénateurs d'ailleurs
gérard larcher a prévenu il n'est pas
question de donner un blanc-seing
jusqu'au 31 juillet 2022 il faut que ça
soit sous le contrôle du parlement ça
veut dire que en février nous devront
débattre à nouveau de la poursuite du
processus de sortie de l'urgence c'est
une atteinte aux libertés individuelles
et collectives
ça ne peut se faire que sous le contrôle
du parlement dans une démocratie
parlementaire
parmi les amendements adoptés à
l'assemblée celui qui porte sur la
connaissance du statut vaccinal des
élèves par les directeurs
d'établissement l'exécutif y voit une
façon je cite d'organiser des conditions
d'enseignement afin de prévenir les
risques de propagation du virus une
mesure qui déchaîne les passions car
elle menace le secret médical selon
certains comme le chef de file des
sénateurs socialistes
ça ne me paraît pas être le rôle d'un
enseignant que de contrôler la situation
sanitaire des enfants je suis très
réservé ce projet de loi arrivera entre
les mains des sénateurs le jeudi 28
octobre prochain la république en marche
ne pouvant compter que sur une vingtaine
d'élus les débats s'annoncent
mouvementées